l'an dernier on vous racontait les
ravages qu'ont fait des oblats
pédophiles dans des communautés
autochtones et ce soir on va aller
encore plus loin
mais d'abord pour se remettre en
contexte voici un extrait de ce qu on
vous révélait l'an dernier alex sait
depuis longtemps qu arthur a aussi été
victime du père couture mais c'est la
première fois que les deux partagent
leur histoire
à deux ils trouvent le courage de
confronter le passé et de revoir avec
nous les chalets utilisé par le
missionnaire pour piéger ses proies et
qui était un but à la pause commence à
signer là-bas - thales est formateur ça
ils ne le disent pas là ce soir
notre enquête nous amener chez deux
nations huit communautés deux villages à
l'autre nous avons découvert l'existence
de prêtres abuseurs en quelques semaines
nous avons pu documenter les agressions
sexuelles commises par dix oblats léché
mais fun plus mon mot membres à celle
d'havas dans sa bouche à 17 ans francis
travail pour le curé alexis genou pour
illustrer les livres de catéchèse
traduit en innu un moment donné tu t'es
plein les bêtes sont dits oui j'ai dit
je veux mettre en fait partie je voulais
fait pas de cette agression lévesque ce
thème qu'est ce qui te dis est mal est
fait m
ma pomme vidéo c'est quoi la justice et
non aucun depuis la diffusion les
témoignages se sont multipliés
voici donc de nouvelles révélations sur
le silence des autorités religieuses et
l'histoire d'un évêque qui a permis aux
abus de se répéter
alex est dans l'excès supplémentaire
unique soit gagnée france et les
français
c'était le premier lexique louis josé
maillot est une anthropologue qui a
passé sa vie chez les i nous c'est une
spécialiste de la langue
et nous quand je vois que ce
dictionnaire ou non les gens qui l'ont
apostrophé dans la rue pour me dire que
le fait qu'ils aient sexe dans mon truc
c'était juge et irrévérencieux si parler
de sexe est plutôt tabou imaginez
lorsqu'il s'agit du curry et de ce qu'il
fait à des ados c'est justement le
message qu'une mère et nous lui demande
de livry alévêque me raconte l t elle
soupçonne qu'il se passe des choses pas
normales avec le missionnaire qui est en
poste chez châtie je m'appelle pietersen
je suis révèle que deux diocèses lavaur
81 pietersen
c'est l'évêque dont nous parlait francis
marque
et l'officier au début des années 80
l'évêque me dit bon bah écoutez c'est
très sérieux ce que vous a légué là je
vais faire enquête et il faut qu'on
établisse les les faits avec tenue rend
le plus grand soin à leur image soit
assuré que je m'en occupe
elle retourne au labrador
au pays de la terre sans arbre où on la
voit ici filmé par le cinéaste pierre
perrault deux à trois semaines après son
retour
la mère l'interpellent joseph kosuth
lévesque est arrivée y est on y vient
faire enquête vient avec moi viens avec
moi pour me servir d'interprète et pim
ce ne sera plus non nous voir en me
voyant fait une irm et succès que ça se
déroule dans le privé alors commencer
l'entrevue et il me dit bombay nous
trouvons que les enlever les jeunes
adolescents passent beaucoup trop de
temps au presbytère et puis ça arrive
très souvent que il ne rentre pas dormir
à la maison alors j'ai traduit tout ça
tu attends et là je les sens il tint
puces sur des charbons ardents je pense
alors il y est bon mais jusqu'ici je ne
dois rien d'anormal alors il est lui de
poursuivre alors et 10 par mois que les
garçons étaient couchés dans l'eure dans
le lit il sentait que le missionnaire
s'introduisait dans leur chambre et
qu'il soulevait la couverture et qu' ils
tentaient de les toucher là alors je
traduis sens là il est devenu blanc
comme seul vous sont sains et il est
descendu était ébranlé il était vraiment
en parler
alors y at il à jean ces termes la dame
que ce sont des accusations très graves
elle dit mais je suis parfaitement
conscient que ce sont des accusations
très graves c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
en parler à lui alors il dit nous allons
faire enquête c'est sûr et il me dit ah
toi je recommande la plus grande
discrétion n'est ce pas
le missionnaire sous enquête est un haut
blanc léonard paradis sans nouvelles
j'ose y retourne voir la mer elle
imagine toi que l'évêque est venu et
puis a dit qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de
faire de poursuites ni quoi que ce soit
parce qu'il ya il a interviewé les
jeunes garçons il y avait plein de
contradictions à leurs témoignages
iman dit il je soupçonne que les garçons
étaient partiellement complices qu'ils
aiment et sort des enfants complices qui
aimait ça selon l'évêque
peu de temps après il a muté paradis il
l'a muté à oujda site dans un endroit
encore plus isolé où il n'y avait pas de
témoins rennes 1 et gts était d'envoyer
le loup dans la bergerie
sept ans plus tard
léonard paradis plaide coupable à des
accusations d'attouchements sexuels sur
des jeunes de 13 à 17 ans sa sentence
trois ans de probation ces gens-là
offert autant parce que quelqu'un au
dessus d'eux ou autour d'eux des
protégés de déplacer une paroisse a noté
arnaud à l'allumette en province allô
léonard paradis a depuis quitté la
prêtrise
il vit à ottawa où nous l'avons joint il
ne veut pas commenter
l'évêque sautonne est devenu archevêque
et les morts sans jamais avoir eu à
répondre de son mutisme année jusqu'ici
il ya très très très peu des vagues en
responsabilité qui ont été traduits
devant les tribunaux pour non assistance
à des enfants qui ont été violées
l'évêque sothen avait aussi protéger le
père alexis joveneau un autre oblats qui
aurait agressé des dizaines dit nous sur
la basse côte nord
or nous apprenons que joe venons a
profité de la complicité d'un confrère
au maire provencher dow à chaque manioc
tenait pour agresser sexuellement une
adolescente en sa présence
aujourd'hui adultes encore traumatisé la
personne dû rester anonyme
mais voici ce qu'elle raconte alexis
joveneau est venu me chercher à l'école
pour aller souper avec lui au maire
provencher
je veux nos s'est assis avec moi sur le
siège arrière de la voiture
alors que provencher lui conduisait
pendant tout le trajet il m'a agressé il
se parlait tous les deux en même temps
c'était partition la rumba joveneau est
décédé joint au téléphone au maire
provencher dit ne pas se souvenir de cet
événement la loire le rhône au quotidien
l'avocat alain arsenault est marquée par
les histoires des 150 victimes qui
poursuivent les oblats dans un recours
collectif
pourtant ce n'est pas sa première
poursuite contre des organisations
religieuses nous à notre bureau
on a eu des différends de couronnes
environ 700 litres
je connais mon bureau d'avocats ils sont
environ 400 iso en 1400 victimes et
aussi que c'est pour une victime qui
dénonça neufs qui ne dénoncent pas
multiplier au sort par neuf ça vous
donne une idée de l'ampleur du phénomène
au québec et voilà pourquoi qu'il
devrait y avoir un consommateur
lorsqu'il ya enquête on découvre des
êtres si tu es idiot en pennsylvanie une
perquisition a permis de mettre la main
sur un demi million de pages d'archivés
et ainsi des masques et 300 prêtres
prédateurs qui ont fait plus de 1000
victimes
on y apprend écouter dont que des
prêtres donner à certaines victimes une
croix en médaillon signe aux autres
prédateurs
quelles étaient les cibles idéales en
australie c'est aussi une commission
royale d'enquêté qui a permis de
démontrer que 7 à 10% des prêtres était
pédophile
pourquoi on ne on hésite encore à les
demander des comptes exigées des comptes
obtenir de réponse lire voir à entendre
les témoignages
mais comment voulez vous savoir
l'ampleur du drame si vous n'êtes même
pas les voir dans les archives de
l'église catholique que ce soit le
diocèse de montréal les québécois y a
quant au recours collectif la
négociation à l'amiable menées avec les
aubes la traîne depuis un an et demi
sans qu'il n'ya eu des excuses c'est non
non non on est marié à riez riez
donc c'est un capacités de
reconnaissance
c'est ce qui le thé le début de la
solution et c'est ça qu'on ne peut pas
obtenu à la connaissance première des
gens la reconnaissent un jeu sur les
victimes lors d'un besoin d'être un
premier temps d'une reconnaissance
[Musique]